Oh family-friendly pic sciencing
family-friendly Felix welcome welcome
everyone clap it up clap it up everybody
I don't know I'm not making any money as
you may have know there's a IED
apocalypse going on right now there's
there's no ass on YouTube no ways okay
they're all gone they all pulled out
because apparently there was a ads on a
racist video so everyone was like uh I'm
up all right there's there's what nine
billion videos on YouTube I don't want
that raises on it no I'm up one not a
nine billion [ __ ] you if you see an ad
on this video you praise that [ __ ] like
the [ __ ] Sun okay grace that [ __ ] for
I want you to suck that family-friendly
Felix here by the way I want you to
gently make sweet it's family friendly
[Applause]
[Music]
we could learn how to use this [ __ ]
soundboard all right so let's have a
look here and see what's in my last
video make on ads hundred dollars the
irony here is that I made more on
YouTube read revenue so check out my new
show ah oh wait [ __ ] they [ __ ] that up
to the new satellite that broke this
story about the racist video was none
other the enemy of YouTube The Wall
Street Journal I'm not kidding they're
back at it again hey remember when I did
the whole try again [ __ ] try
again [ __ ] you weren't supposed
to actually do it what the hell man god
damn it
[ __ ] [ __ ] YouTube right I'm [ __ ]
okay I'm just don't panic I'm sure no
one else is panicking I declare war on
The Wall Street Journal okay maybe
people are panicking just
it just a little bit that's fine
desperate times cause comes desperate
measurements and family friendly Felix
got a plan
born I got a I've got a plan how did we
do it back in the day okay how did they
do it back in the good old day on
YouTube seven years ago this is the
content we need to go back to okay this
is 10 times better it's genius it's
brilliant it's almost a billion views my
summers name is minecraft the game that
I've been avoiding since I started doing
YouTube minecraft the best game and the
goddamn were minecraft
that's what people want minecraft more
minecraft we need more minecraft and
finally I'm going to play minecraft I
haven't played it and I go to know how
many years I'll refuse to play it but
here we 18 pounds I can't afford that
luckily I'm Swedish and I have a secret
secret a secret plan for this this is
wait doesn't the windows come with oh it
does it says okay cool
hey it's cheaper [ __ ] that free trial
add your Microsoft I don't have a
Microsoft account it's hard to be
family-friendly ok Tom's Tom's guide yes
this is what I wanted yeah
I quit I quit I'm now living in the
Minecraft world hello sheep you'll be my
new friend they do role-playing when
they play Minecraft so they do like
funny voices
hello I am sheep the memes they're sheep
what did you build over there alone I
don't know see I'm really good at this
I'm really good at this oh hell ah
god dammit Jake you go get it yo you go
get it go get it boy
maybe she likes to [ __ ] me
gotta get no regrets
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
people play this game every day alright
then I guess if I'm going to live in the
new Minecraft world I need to build a
house this is where I live now okay
god dammit it's going to be pretty
[ __ ] cool guys I mean pretty cool
it's going to be pretty swell and also
just know that there is not a platform
and services related to virtual
communities in which members interact
primarily on the Internet okay this is
not that you know I'm actually enjoying
playing the game which makes me think
maybe a high of autism after all I'm
building a wall I'm building a wall if
trumps not going to do it
family-friendly felix is going to do it
alright we're going to build a wall you
know the whole concept with
family-friendly Nets people aren't just
going to go back on it okay the reason
why people love YouTube is because it's
free and it's open and you can say
whatever you want it's not like
television where everything is behind
executive producers and people telling
no you can't say that because then we'll
do this no we can't say that yeah it
seems like YouTube is forced to turning
into television at this point that's
going to be bad for everyone you want
you to continue being a free platform I
would want you to be in a free platform
I understand that advertisers needs to
feel like they're spending money and it
doesn't show up on racist videos I
understand that 100% like that's a
terrible thing if I was spending money
and I see my ad showing operations
videos I'd be like but the whole thing
is just so massively overblown it's so
typical for these things to just
way bigger than they should be in the
media talking first hand here it's like
what five videos that they discovered
instead of based on the whole platform
there's like what nine billion videos on
YouTube and and people are worried about
five
I agree like it's still a problem but if
it should everyone on the platform be
affected by five racist dudes and that
just doesn't really make sense to me at
least
I'm sure YouTube will bounce back and I
hope I pray for everyone that's a
smaller channel that they can hang in
there for a nap because I used to be in
a point on YouTube where I was so
dependent on my next paycheck I didn't
have anything set up I had just started
off and I needed that monthly paycheck
so this month most likely a lot of
creators are not going to get paid so
it's a way to combat that just a little
bit I wanted to do another shout-out
competition I've done a couple in the
past so if you're interested in getting
a shout out they've been they've been
successful and pretty good so check out
the link in description there's a
specific rules and I really appreciate
that you go by them make sure that you
are quick and concise with following
them if there's too much text I'm not
going to have time to read it and I'm
just going to skip it
no smugness intended but I'm fine like
I'm not going to stop making videos just
because I'm not making money I I meant
it when I said I'd do it because I love
it and that being said if you see an ad
oh also I'm going to twitch now look I
decided this before okay before anything
is so don't read it the wrong way but I
wanted to start doing streams on Twitch
so we're going to do a weekly stream
over at which it starts Sunday this
Sunday I mean so over at youtube.com
slash neck below neck below is the brand
that I wanted to create
that I wanted to rebel mode to be but no
one liked the name check the Emmy nickel
it means cooler on the internet than in
person I think that's a pretty [ __ ]
perfect name so it's going to be a
streaming show once a week potentially
more I really want it to be something
sort of like we did with rebel mode like
we did with cringe modes because that
was just so much fun so definitely be
sure to check that out come show your
support praise you know and all that
stuff
[Music]